you brought great energy to the show
congrats but when you talk about kyland
how do you feel about your relationship
now i would think quite betrayed
backstab the list goes on oh absolutely
my relationship with kyland um there is
no relationship um i absolutely do feel
betrayed i do feel backstabbed and
honestly i'm just very very surprised
that colin showed his true colors this
early in the game um if you're gonna
make a deal with someone my expectation
going into that is that you're going to
follow through with that deal but
instead he tried making excuses to why
that deal was not going to go through on
his terms and that was just never said
in our deal so he was making up things
trying to find other ways to make
himself look better through the end and
it just wasn't working so
in this game i really value the fact
that i played this game with integrity
and i was to myself 100 i can't say the
same for him i respect the fact that he
needed to make this move if he felt that
i was the most unpredictable person in
the house first game but i don't respect
the fact you showed your two colors and
you lied about the deal so do i feel
betrayed absolutely and i really hope he
walks through that door next
you were an emotional player and you
were put on the block four times why was
the house obsessed with you would you be
more cutthroat or are you proud of how
you played you know i'll be really
honest with you is still a question i
try and understand to this day
being in the house i really didn't feel
like i was a target but just the whole
thing is compared to all the other
females in the house the only two people
that have won a competition or even i
come close were myself and alyssa and so
to everybody else in the house when i'd
be working out they'd be like oh you
should probably work out a little bit
less because you're going to be seen as
a threat or a competitor and i'm like
but i'm just working out like he was
just from the get-go i looked like an
athlete and i'm a female so i just the
target kind of came on me pretty easily
which i wasn't really expecting when i
walked into the house but at the same
token i am proud of the game that i
played i was in a position where i
couldn't play the cup throw game that i
wanted to because i was on the block and
trying to survive so when you're on the
block four times you need to play a
survival game and my game switched from
playing cutthroats playing strategic in
the way of how can i use the block to
better my game so what i've liked to
play cutthroat game i mean absolutely i
wanted to slip some people's throats
into this game nicely of course and get
them out the house but could i have done
that in the position that i was in
not really so for me i am proud of the
game that i played i fought like hell i
was the true underdog of the season no
one had to fight harder than i did in
this game so i'm 100 proud of that no
regrets in this game no way
who do you think is the next person to
leave the house and why are they who you
want to leave okay so who i want to
leave the house next is absolutely
kailan um do i think he will be the next
person to leave the house i don't think
so i truly think the next person to
leave the house is either going to be
hannah sarah bath or alyssa i was
alyssa's only female shield i told her
if i left she was the one that was
coming next depending on who won the hoh
i would love to see sarah beth walk
through those doors because she really
has shown her true colors i mean when
you ask me to throw a veto to you twice
when i'm sitting next to you on the
block that doesn't look the hottest and
obviously hannah's playing a really
under the radar game so i would not mind
seeing her in that house either because
i had four votes going into yesterday
china was the fifth one that i needed
and she didn't want to pull through so
i'd be okay with her walking through
that house too
the vote was 7-1 do you think your
friendship with aza will continue
outside of big brother what did it mean
to have her in the house oh my goodness
ozza is my best friend in the house oz
has been my numero uno since day uno i
love aza she's incredible and i know for
me she's gonna be not only my friend
outside of this house she's gonna be my
soul sister my best friend outside of
this house when you have someone who you
go through that much together she
supported me every single time that i
was on the block no matter what she was
always there to talk to i was always
there for her whenever she needed
someone so no absolutely aza made my big
brother experience complete and i know i
wanted to come out of it with one best
friend or two best friends and i came up
with a whole household but aza and big d
for that matter both have a extremely
special place in my heart
who do you think will go far in the game
to be honest with you i really think
xavier is going to go really far in this
game he is playing such an under the
radar game for how big of a threat he is
in this house and when kyle and asks
last week who i thought was the most
influential person in the house in terms
of people listening to what that person
has to say xavier is the person i think
of every single time i really do think
no one xavier is on no one's radar so i
really do think he's going to get very
far in the house and i also really think
oz is going to get really really far in
this house no one really sees her as a
target right now and i think it's going
to center forward